you
yes I remember learning a good number of
things coming to these to these meetups
the ML Meetup and all these things so
it's I really consider it a big honor to
be able to speak here for the first time
actually um so I think Paul and everyone
who's organizing it for for asking me to
come and and and talk for a little bit
so what I would like to talk about today
is text processing so I've been thinking
about text processing for a little while
now in building a bunch of different
things in different sectors for
different groups of people just as a
small two-second background I'm really a
math guy I was doing pure math for a
long time and then I went into the data
science space and said you become an
engineer to some extent so this is so I
did a lot of you know behavioral
modeling I did a lot of financial
modeling and the tande then in last
year-plus I've really ended up building
a lot of things in the text processing
space and I find it a fascinating space
that that is open both in the research
in the industry and from an engineering
from a statistics from a machine
learning perspective there are just many
many things to do many things to think
about and I don't think it's a it's a
space that's going to get smaller I
think it's just gonna get bigger and
bigger so hopefully everything I'll tell
you about is easy and hopefully most of
it is high performance at least what I
think of as high performance but feel
free to interrupt and ask questions
there'll be some time for questions at
the end and maybe a tutorial if I if I
have the time but please jump in okay so
here's the outline of the talk I'll give
a little bit of a background as to what
kinds of text processing problems I was
asked to solve which were the most
important in my beginning to think about
the structure of these things the
structure of text processing the
structure of working with textual data
in the world that that we have now give
a couple of examples of the major
projects that I've been on and still on
and some of them and then we'll talk
about how I do these things
and
talk about some of the technical aspects
talk about the philosophy I'll refer a
lot to the rosetta library which which
is a library that Ian Lang wore who
might be here at some point and myself
have put together there's a number of
contributors other contributors as well
and it's really a text processing geared
library solving a lot of those types of
problems all right
so one project that has gotten me to
think a lot about text processing and in
general in human-computer interaction
with regards to textual archives or
textual information is the
declassification engine which is a
project at Columbia University and it's
a it's a far-reaching project it's in
part with the Brown Institute which is
connected to Stanford and and to
Columbia and it's it's run by David
Madigan who's was who is a statistician
well-known statistician well there's Ian
now say hello and math Connolly who's a
professor of history and essentially the
idea is to bring together computer
scientists historians statisticians and
data scientists from from from industry
as well as from the private the academic
environment to build tools for
historians to be able to interact with
large archives and in particular the
archives that they're looking at here
are released government documents so
declassified documents cables telephone
transcriptions and so on and so on a lot
of the FOIA Freedom of Information Act
documents and so on so one problem that
we end up thinking about quite a bit is
the sort of cold start problem right you
have a very large data a large database
or a database of some size of documents
and you as a historian need to go and
look somewhere right and keyword search
is not sufficient to solve this problem
in most in most instances because you
don't first of all you don't even know
what you're looking for half of the time
and even if you do it's very it's hard
to formulate in a beautiful boolean
expression what it exactly what it is
that you're looking for
and most historians of course don't have
you know amazing units and grip skills
so most of the boolean expressions are
really going to be disjunctive that they
use so one way to approach this problem
is to think about anomaly detection and
anomaly detection in this case can be
semantic anomaly so for example here's
an example and some basic results of an
latent Dursley allocation topic model
which looks at cables emanating from
different embassies and looks at the
semantics associated with those cables
and starts to look for some patterns
right so one of the things that this was
actually a project that in Ian started
up one of the things that you notice is
that if you look at cables which which
which spring away from the topic that
that they're mostly associated with they
turn out to be secret cables finds
cables that were originally classified
as secret potentially this is an
interesting fact potentially it's not
interesting historically but this gives
a way for people to start looking at
things right you can start looking at
these at exactly these cables or these
pieces of documents that that are make
that are bringing forth these results
right so it's a way to start another
even sort of simpler or as more
simplistic approach as looking at
frequency analysis right so you have
metadata that you're potentially
extracting from the text itself maybe
joining with from the metadata that you
have and you're looking at frequencies
right and you're looking at spikes and
frequencies maybe you're modeling you're
having like a Kleinberg model of the
communication stream or something like
that which is going to be highlighting
when things happen that you don't expect
to happen right so here's a trivial
example there's a spike in J in October
first spike in October 73
that's the yom kippur war you can pull
up the cable of course this is obvious
to historian but potentially the other
spikes are not right so that's sort of
an anomaly couple of examples of anomaly
detection another project that that Ian
and I were on last year was a large was
building a large e discovery pipeline
and if you've ever thought about what
lawyers have to deal with it's well
let's again
took math right because what they
generally get handed over during the
discovery or post-production process is
a large collection of documents these
are emails contracts memos Excel
spreadsheets and so on and so on and so
on and these could be hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of documents and
they have a limited amount of time and
limited number of amount of resources
before deposition and they're supposed
to be able to interact with the system
without it being random right so one of
the things you're going to end up doing
is you're gonna you need to be able to
determine or give some sort of
classification system we're gonna pull
up relevant documents and the definition
of relevant is is is up to them really
so you can end up doing something like
this right some sort of a thing that's
gonna feed into a classifier it's gonna
involve a bunch of cleaning parsing
tokenizing and so on and so on and
generally you want these things to be
pretty fast these are not potentially
online you know processes but you want
fast turnaround times you don't want
things to wait for days you want to
compute for days and you also want to be
able to experiment you want to build
things modular literally in a flexible
way so you know one of the big things
you're going to be doing is feature
extraction right you're going to be
taking a document you're going to be
pulling out the signals you care about
the features the tokens whatever you
want to call it and one of the things
you're gonna realize really really
quickly is that if you just do this in a
sort of loggerhead way you're gonna blow
up memory right you're just gonna have
too many features if your features or
words or even if you look at the word
stamps and so on and so on they just
won't actually fit and moreover you know
if they do fit they'll make your machine
learning tasks really hard right so you
need to think about either reducing
these number of words or using some
appropriate sparse data structure and
associated learning algorithms so what
are some typical machine learning goals
that I've had to deal with in the last
year so classification right document
classification or ranking you know
sentiment analysis recommendation
systems right a lot of these are
semantic base now anomaly detection like
I mentioned before communication
dynamics metadata extraction this is a
big deal as well sometimes you want to
actually be able to get things out of
the documents themselves which means
jeez you're not doing any sort of
statistics which are doing a large
processing parsing extraction task
network extraction right that's a big
deal on social network authorship
attribution and so on and so on right
there are many many tasks and sort of
what is the general like the very very
high-level flow look like well you start
with a corpus this corpus might live in
a hard drive and a database coming from
an API maybe a web scraping whatever
you're going to be pushing that to
something that's gonna be processing the
date the documents tokenizing it feature
extracting features hashing maybe
pulling out some metadata you want maybe
merging that with metadata that's given
to you and then you're going to be
pushing that to a machine learning task
right whatever that might be and this
could be you know there could be an act
of learning bitter part of this it there
could be you know optimization online
optimization many variants but this is
sort of the general very basic framework
and so what is actually hard about text
processing well in order to for this
thing to actually work and run you have
to think about data structures and
generally use sparse data structures
because things don't fit in memory its
language right language is it difficult
for pretty much the obvious reasons the
actual parsing and feature extraction
can be really radically different from
one collection to another you know
something a legal team is going to give
you is gonna be completely different
from like you know a collection of
webpages right it might be even
difficult to get these things into
machine readable format right sometimes
part of your process might be a Dino
identifying the original encoding of the
document or identifying the original
format of the document right you might
have a database dump just dot txt files
where some of these were Excel some of
these were Gmail some of these remembers
and you have different processes for
dealing with that and a lot of the sort
of software development has been geared
towards you know huge data drives huge
scalable distributive systems Hadoop and
all of these things and for the most
part this isn't the problem we're trying
to solve right we're not it's not a
facebook problem or a Google problem
it's really a problem with dealing with
a fairly stable collection in particular
right a database that maybe doesn't grow
that quickly or maybe
at all and and providing tools and being
able to process that in a fast and agile
way and there also isn't really a simple
solution in the way that there is one
for the new for the numeric stack write
numeric processing we know how to do
that if we want to do machine learning
in Python let's say we know we can take
SK learn we can take panda's we can take
numpy we can take steps models we have a
nice collection of tools we think about
text processing you know what is that
collection of tools so there's something
to think about and that's what Ian and I
were thinking about when we ended up
putting this library together and what's
fun about text processing well they're
pretty much the same things that are
hard about it at least from my
perspective and you have to care about
memories you have to care about
engineering and processing speed and all
the things that come with NLP and if
you're a UNIX fan like I am you get to
do quite a bit of unix and python is
really nice although python isn't
exclusively the nice language for that
and then you have to whatever ecosystem
you're in you're probably whether it's
I'm going to do most of my examples in
Python but pretty much everything
applies to to R and to whatever it is
that you use you can end up stepping out
of that ecosystem so you have to think
about how to do that in an efficient
testable scalable way as well so the
first thing is you know what's the first
thing in the agenda well dealing with
limited memory so how do you how do you
deal with limited memory well you know
there's the hardware piece of it which
means you know what machine do you want
to use and and my answer to that is that
you know don't think about clusters
right don't think about you know a
highly distributed system that you have
to manage that you have to deal with the
actual distribution with the over the
over the net over the network you create
and so on and so on a lot of the
solutions if you do if you write code
well and you optimize the code can be
solved and much cheaper much simpler
machines like Ian did a lot of the work
on his system76 laptop which is not an
expensive laptop but it has really nice
really nice hardware right you can do it
on this which is much more expensive and
has about the same hardware or you can
buy you know like at some point we
needed something just slightly more
powerful and we just bought a machine
which is upgradable cost like six to
seven grand we stuck it in a in a closet
with lots of fans it was still too loud
and then we
down in a server center and and that
basically took care of all the problems
we could envision for a while and and we
weren't dealing with small small data
sets or you can go AWS or digitalocean
or any of these things so you know if
you do this very basic you know
back-of-the-envelope memory calculations
you know if you think about how much
memory text is gonna take if you put it
in your in your CPU it's gonna take
pretty much the same as a hard drive it
can take more so one obvious thing to do
is to hash everything right I mean if
you think numbers you know doubles take
eight bytes right so 1 million doubles
will take 8 megabytes and so on and so
on right so you can save a lot of space
just by using the right hash map or the
right in the right data structure which
we'll see in a second
so and the other thing we do quite a bit
is from a philosophical sense we monitor
memory a lot and we think about that all
the time and and we monitor with things
like H stop and which doesn't work on
this computer and I stat by the way H
stop does work on Macs but it tends it
has a tendency to give you the wrong
results so but there are other solutions
but but just the consciously thinking
about that and all your processing and
all your code writing actually actually
helps a lot
it might sound banal but if you're if
you commit to it it will help and the
other thing is that a lot of the text
processing tasks if you actually think
about it are not memory intensive tasks
especially the tokenization bit right
because realistically speaking what do
you care about you have a gigantic
collection of documents you don't
actually care about the collection of
documents you only care about the tokens
or the features or the signals you're
gonna extract from them right so
essentially what you really want to do
is you want to just take this collection
and you want to transform it into
whatever it is that you want to use and
that transformation is pretty much once
you've set it up once you know how to do
it you know you're gonna take all the
words you can take all the now so you're
gonna step whatever it is that you can
take the first letter of every word
whatever it is that it might be the the
the actual entities themselves the
documents isn't that the process is
independent of the
of the different documents right you can
you can feature extract on one document
and feature extract and another right so
you know one of the one of the ways to
do that is to stream write or even if
you have a very large document you're
dealing with you know you know 19th
century not romantic novels or something
like this you can stream these things
line by line right which means that you
never keep anything in memory right and
you're always writing to standard out
you're always writing to disk here was
writing to some sparse data structure
that you care about
right do this file at a document at a
time file at a time line at a time or
combinations thereof so and the other
thing is just think about this sort of
machine you know once you're thinking
all the way through to the end of the
pipeline think about the machine
learning algorithms you're gonna use
right you know what's the sort of nice
equivalent of streaming well you know
machine learning algorithms that use to
cast a gradient descent you know we'll
see an example of LD a topic modeling
which uses just implemented in a library
called vocal rabbit which is does
exactly that which is much much faster
than the other implementations so you
know very very basic summation of
dealing with limited memory just stream
as much as you want as much as you can
and then deal with huge feature counts
by sparse data structures stochastic
gradient descent or just to reduce the
number of features you care with off the
bat by doing intelligent things like
throwing away stop words or throwing
away things you don't really care about
but don't put everything in memory only
keep in memory which you need at any
given moment so this this is one of the
reasons you don't really a lot of times
you don't really need very big very
powerful machines right because it
doesn't matter what your memory is
you're keeping very little in there so
what about making things actually faster
well you know one of the generic goals
as I mentioned is tokenizing right so
tokenization if you haven't done it
essentially is going to it in as a very
simple example is going to be taking
some sentence getting rid of the things
you don't actually want and leaving the
words you care about right this could be
a much more involved process it can
involve quite a bit of NLP
you can be using you know you can be a
part of speech tagging you could be
stamping you can be leavitt eyes you
could be taking Viagra you can do many
many things but but essentially what
you're gonna be doing is taking some
string and breaking it up into a bunch
of other strings which you might have so
for example here you know here's a
sentence let's do a deal trade some
money and they take words you care about
out of those okay
so how would you do that well you might
write a very very simple function like
this which is involves a bunch of for
loops right and then there's some
cleaning up right so it throws out your
stuff words it takes care of your
punctuation and takes care of your text
so you might think this is perfectly
fine but then you go off and you test it
and you see how long it takes right well
this is you know a pretty serious amount
of time this thing is taking to run
right so you time it this is a nice UNIX
utility time right we use this all the
time and so you go and you say well this
is never gonna work for me because I
have to do this you know 10 million
times or something like that right and
and and and and the documents are fairly
long so you start optimizing it so you
start to think how do I make it faster
well you know maybe you want to switch
to a regular expression right regular
expression in Python as a C C base
library it's optimized it's fast if you
do that okay you test it again right you
get something faster or if you want to
be a bit more pedantic and actually do
something that will tell you exactly
what's happening to your code you can
line profile it R has last nice liner
line profilers Python has a really nice
line profilers they'll tell you exactly
how much time is being spent on exactly
each line of code right so if we look at
our now second version of the tokenizer
we see that most of the time is spent on
the on line 62 right and then after that
most time is spent on line 61 so we
realize that something is big is slowing
us down that if we do this if statement
we do that check you know what is
actually happening well we just we think
about how to make that faster well one
obvious answer is to think about data
structure right or
what objects are you gonna use stop
words as a list right so so what do we
do them well one one easy thing to do is
replace that list with a set right said
as a hash you don't have to do it's a
much faster lookup and you reduce your
time just by doing like a trivial
trivial change and the reason you knew
how to do that change is because you
profiled right and these things become
incredibly important when dealing with
with dealing with large collections a
test text because essentially these are
the things that are gonna make you you
know take 1 minute or 10 hours right so
here's you know here's a basic example
of the two to two options right so one
is using set is is is significantly
faster right I mean you can see the
result all right and we use different
nice to use different utilities you time
unix time or you can time in python here
it says time at use do 250 loops or and
here you see the time yeah cool yeah
sorry so your question is about the how
going from the collection of text to the
classifier I mean you never so the point
is that you never you try to never
return to the original documents right
you try to do things in an online and a
stream fashion right we're processing
thing you once you process the document
once you get everything out of it you
want you hashed it basically yeah
I mean I guess it's just that's a very
specific question right you're asking
like you know the question is does what
happens what happens if you have a
collection right and the collection is
somehow updated the actual individual
documents in them are updated you know
how do you deal with that well I mean
that that I mean you do notice things
change right I mean you know that you if
you if you know I get maybe if I'm
understanding your question I mean like
it really depends on the task right if
your task is to be able to identify it's
going to be very different identified
change is going to be very different if
your task is to tokenize into a bunch of
words and then and then classify right
so you're gonna have a different process
yeah with government documents that's
actually a big deal and like and we do
and we do work with multiple versions of
the same document that has been redacted
over time
but a lot of that problem is an OCR
problem is an image recognition problem
at first because you don't even know
where the reductions happen so that's a
completely different story
so basically what you're saying is that
suppose I want to tokenize a piece of
text and I'm interested in buy grams
right so these are tuples of words right
that are next to each other however I
have a collection of stop words which I
don't want to be part of that right or
you want it to be sensible I mean one
way is that you can also just drop them
right you can always drop them from from
from initially right cuz and and then
you can put your buy grams together
right or you can consider that a break
like a sentence break so you could split
on on your stop words first does that
make sense yeah yeah yeah I mean I guess
it just depends on the context right I
mean I don't know I don't think there is
it it's gonna be a canonical and okie
answer for that right it just depends on
what you want to do but you know a
natural thing to do would be just to
split on notes right because in the end
like it also depends how often that
happens and how much you actually care
about what the language is saying as
opposed to you just want to be able to
group things together and see if they if
these are grouped like this and they
appear here and they're a group like
that and they appear there then that's
statistically indicative of something
right that's what you want like you're
also going to be running the same
process on hopefully on of tokenization
on the entire corpus right so whatever
is gonna be creating these the signal
stream that's gonna be going into your
class into your machine learning bit is
gonna have the same process on the front
on the front on the back end of it so
that's going to be uniform
I mean I think a lot of that is gonna
come into some sort of you know
exploratory data analysis phase right I
mean you have to start from somewhere
right unless you have absolutely no
choice and you know that you will not
see any of these documents until you
have to tokenize them you know imagine
it's just gonna be like you have to go
now and somebody's like here's your API
just start hitting the API and start
test T and start like and start
optimizing this recommendation system
right there are cold start problems like
this it's not it's not crazy right so
then okay then you do your best best
tokenizer guessed which is like the
simplest one but generally like when
you're dealing with a collection you get
to see it you need you to do some
exploratory do some NLP on it right
there's something that's gonna feed it
and everything and sort of everything we
built you we have you know there's the
NLT k-cup tokenizer there's the the
Stanford library we we built some
optimized basic tokenizer because we
just thought the NLT K ones were very
slow but you can the way we write
everything is that the tokenizer
function is just a parameter in
everything you do
so you write the tokenizer function
that's custom to your to your process
custom to your language right yeah I
mean the performance issue this question
about performance the performance issues
that really just gonna come from from
the task at hand right but but the
philosophy is that you shouldn't the
tokenization bit shouldn't have
performance issues right because you can
you can tokenize one line at a time you
can tokenize and characters at a time
you can tokenize one file at a time
rights as long as your tokenization bit
isn't isn't slow like as long as you've
lined profiled it and you've gotten it
to the best you can maybe you've got the
best data structures you've wrote it
really well maybe you scythe on maybe
you used whatever you see anything you
need right as long as that bit is fast
everything else shouldn't impede its
speed because everything else is
completely paralyzed upon which we'll
talk about in a second right we good
okay
so just back to that's you you could
profile more you can you can say that
you can see the the the speed up right
you can see where your problems might be
right so you can just iterate on this
process you can put a list comprehension
which is which is going to be faster
because I as a fast append it's like a
loop etc etc might look nicer to you if
you have some sort of an aesthetic
disposition towards code and then you
time it total time and so on
I'm not claiming that this example here
some sort of an optimized tokenizer but
this is the sort of process we do all
the time with everything like every bit
that you're going to use right before
before it gets fed into the pipeline in
the stream before it gets paralyzed we
try to we try to do this sort of stuff
with it and then think about the data
structures right because you you have a
lot of really great languages and Python
and are they're really powerful and so
and so and they have all these brilliant
convenient high level data structures
but some of those come with huge
overhead you know list lookup verses set
lookup Python dictionaries the doesn't
allow the compiler to allocate you know
memory in blocks right next to each
other right so you know it's gonna be
inherently slower a lot of the time you
might use a more lightweight or simpler
data structure which you can create
yourself right you can just write a
class here's my data structure this is
all I need and is going to tell the
compiler how to allocate memory more
intelligently right in the way you would
do it in Cu C++ right there's a really
nice blog post about this that's just I
think right on which you can see here by
the way the slides will be available
with all the hyperlinks inside and the
other thing is of course as I've
mentioned this a number of times is that
all of this consumable all of this is
paralyzed herbal right these documents
have nothing a lot of times have nothing
to do with each other the API calls
might be completely independent the web
pages are independent everything is
independence you do this completely
independently right so in theory it's
infinitely scalable and and and so you
just have to figure out how to do that
so the in Python and there's a really
brilliant library you know the multi
processing library in our there's also
really nice multi processing libraries I
have
I am coated in our in a little while but
I'm certainly remember using them from a
year or so ago I'm sure they're better
now and so here's an example of a
paralyzed process that's that spawns
four sub processes it pickles our
function and iterable and pipes into
side process right so it's a very very
this is you know just a few lines of
code and we've paralyzed it right so we
can run it on in four streams in
parallel right so there are certain
issues that come along with that right
you don't really get everything for free
when you you can't just hit something
with a with a pair with a multi
processing library of sorts and just
hope it all worked just like chef
functions into some black box and
iterables or or lists or whatever you
have to think about it a little bit so
you know for example what happens if
your function isn't one variable right
but you're trying to paralyze over some
iterable or over some list which is one
of the variables in the functions one of
the arguments the other thing is that
this thing depends on pickling pickling
is not possible for all functions you
have to think about that and the other
thing is that what does that mean to
debug right so we do quite a bit of
debugging so you know use Python PDB PDP
plus plus and so on and so on what
happens if you have a paralyze process
and you're trying to debug right that's
not really possible so so it's kind of
sucks if you're gonna be writing code
which you have to write some other code
in order to debug the code and then you
paralyze the code and then maybe there's
something broken and then you still
can't step through it right and X etc
etc so that there aren't the the
libraries nice but there are things you
need to think about so one of these some
of these problems are easy to solve for
example if you have functions of many
variables you can use partial which is
essentially a wrapper it's just it's a
it's almost like a decorator returns a
function of the other area of the
variable you care about so here's an
example right you have a function of two
variables and X you define your function
of a which is a partial where you set a
to three in this case right and then you
prepare
why's that right so now you Fed function
a an iterable which is this list of four
things and three and and you were able
to easily parallelizable some things are
a little bit more and more involved
especially dealing with pickling and
dealing with debugging so a lot of the
work that Ian did on the library had to
do with giving you really nice tools to
be able to do that so there's a function
in the library in the parallel sub
module called map easy which tries to
pickle your function which means it
throws the applicable error it allows
you to set the number of jobs to 1 which
basically is like not paralyzing at all
which allows you to step through it with
the debugger so you basically set it to
one your debug you do everything you
want you set it to minus one which means
use all the available CPUs or whatever
you need and then you're good to go
right and allows you to exit with
control C which is a nice thing I think
without you know shutting down your
there you know there's a whole bunch of
other things you might want to think
about in terms of paralyzation you can
look at I'm a PC which is which which
allows you to send out jobs and return
chunks and so on and so on so there's so
I would just say take a look at Rosetta
parallel there's a couple of things that
will make your life I think a lot easier
especially in the text processing world
but also in general and so the summary
of making things faster is well you know
if you're doing if you're in Python and
you're dealing with or in UNIX and
you're dealing with extracting text you
know use regular expressions right use
the right because they're fast use the
right data structures you know numpy and
pandas for numbers maybe write your own
data structures think about when you
want to use sets versus lists versus
whatever right profile your code as much
as possible profile it in unix time
profile in python with time it line
profile it and so on and so on
use multi-processing whether it's the
multi processing library for python or
the functions that
we wrote for Rosetta and just note that
you know I might be talking about Python
because this is just a convenience for
the moment but pretty much everything
here is completely irrelevant to most of
the environments you work in right
it's definitely relevant to everything
I've ever worked in yeah I mean you're
saying that so the question is what
happens if your bug is thrown by some
document that is so yeah so that's
that's that's actually a decent question
in general so the that might earn you a
book the the the point is that a lot of
the time see if you're thinking of a
one-pass scenario right you don't want
to pass over many many times you
actually want to keep information about
what you pass other than whatever the
tokens other than the hash whatever it
is right so we wrote all these streamers
which allow you to cache whatever
information you want right so you know
if you if you allow you know if you
allow for your tokenizer or whatever
function your streamer to say throw an
exception to to accept some sort of an
error you can you can have that duck ID
be cached or the file number a file name
or whatever it is or line number
whatever information you're expecting is
necessary for you to get to where you
need it to be can be actually cached
inside the streaming process right
that's also a lot of ways how how you
might extract matter that metadata right
so imagine you have you're doing a
gigantic directory crawl right and you
wanna tokenize every file every txt file
in the directory but you also want to
keep all the creation times and you want
to keep all the formats and you want to
keep all whatever whatever it is that
you want to keep right and then and you
don't want to do that twice right so you
capture all this information along the
way
and you want to cache potentially you
want to cache bad dock IDs
as well right somewhere where there's an
exception that's throwing you cash that
in and then you deal with that later
that's right right but if the but the
question is might be like I don't I
don't want to stop everything right so
which means you can you can you can
write functions which will catch that
exception and cash whatever whatever
information you want along the way
let's throw it into a file or put it
cash it in the streamer class to what
degree is the system file system I oh
yeah
yes oh so so when and I built that
machine had someone build that machine
for us because we don't know how to
build machines very well we we we bought
the best SSDs we could get basically
that was one of the things right I mean
I don't remember what they would we
bought exactly but we bought some really
nice rated SSDs because we knew that
this was going to be the problem we were
dealing with we cared more about that
than we cared about CPU we had the thing
had 64 gigs of ram but it was totally
upgradable we didn't know when we would
upgraded we cared more about CP disk i/o
than anything and you can get I mean
like you know if you want an online like
digitalocean which is a which is a cloud
service has really great cheap machines
so much that the price is cheap but the
disks and the machines are really nice
there we have really nice SSDs right so
you don't need to build the thing
yourself right or buy it you can
actually you know for $10 a month or $20
a month you can have a pretty nice
machine to your disposal yeah
I mean you care about how fast you're
able to read from the disk well which if
you if you do it I mean you're not doing
it once right I mean you have you have
you have you know you have a terabyte of
data you know read it he it's gonna make
a difference whether it's some crappy
spin disk or it's gonna be a nice SSD
you mean there's a lot of tricks that's
right I mean there's a lot of tricks you
can do to try to optimize this process
you know whatever whatever it is you
want to get out of it in the end right
that's really the question but might but
the point is that the philosophy is just
to not to stream to paralyze to never
worry about memory and to optimize what
it is that actually does the processing
itself right whether it's whether with
nice you know what nice software with
nice hardware and so on yeah I mean not
a there are no we don't really deal we
deal with disk issues right and it's the
sense of like a hardware person would
write will just work with whatever is at
hand and all I know is that if you buy
better s as these you will see better
performance for this sort of stuff
and especially things like you know like
whoop oh a bat which is the LD a piece
of software implementation which is all
disk i/o bound
I mean you can always raid everything
that everything can be backed up sure
but it's a different problem right then
something problem we really want to
think about at the moment right we can
we can think of you know we've about how
what the right optimal machine is for a
given scenario but there is there is
ways to back everything up right just to
to an extent right but sort of the
culmination example that I wanted to go
through and hopefully we'll have time to
see it in the in a step through tutorial
is is one of the things that we play
with a lot which is LD a topic modeling
and this is a statistical approach
developed by bleh and Aang and Jordan
about ten years ago I think they
released their paper and it's a
hierarchical Bayesian model and what did
it attempts to do is attempts to
describe the underlying semantic
structure and the way it sort of does
that is that it sort of imagines that
you have a distribution of distributions
right where each distribution is is a
topic right so by topic what I mean is
like is a distribution of terms so every
document in your collection is some sort
of a mixture of distributions of words
right so one way to think about it is
that you know a convenient way to think
about it is to think about these things
as topics even though they might not be
meaningful in terms of you know human
readability but what what what you can
imagine is that suppose I have this
gigantic corpus and I have an Oracle
which is generating text and the way
this Oracle is generally generate text
is that it's going to first generate a
distribution randomly tree is a
distribution of of the tokens or the
words that I see in my text and then
from that distribution choose a word
right so you can think of every single
document as some sort of a mixture of
these randomly chosen distributions of
these topics and then then the words
that appear with a given probability of
a given weight from these distributions
right so it's not spectacular
explanation about the topic modeling
it's kind of a more or less involved
statistical bit but essentially the two
things you
to worry about is that there's there's a
parameter that's gonna control the
distribution of these topics right these
kind of groups of words right you can
think of that about these topics as
essentially ways of saying you know this
document has these groups of words and
within each group we have certain words
appearing with certain weights or
certain probability frequencies so
there's going to be a parameter is going
to be controlling these groups of words
and there's going to be a parameter
that's going to be controlling the
actual word probabilities themselves and
as an aside this has you know the the LD
a topic modeling has very little to do
with text processing per se except the
fact that it was motivated by it you can
use it in all sorts of different
scenarios they have nothing to do with
text or language or any of these things
and and and one of the things that that
that we like the vopo Abbott
implementation for is that is that it's
an online you know gradient descent
learning algorithm right which
essentially means that it's and it's
written well right up to my C++ code
there are other ones there's there's a
nice library called jinsim in python
which is really really nice but you're
gonna have a lot of a lot of dump a lot
of time to wait every time you want to
do something we're talking about you
know something that might take ten hours
in and Jensen might take you know a
minute or two in vocal rabbit the and
this is the reason that it actually
works fairly fast
however there's a caveat right Jensen is
really nice because it's a Python
library you pip install it you have nice
ways to interact with the data pipe the
data and get it out everything is Python
local here you have something completely
different
right completely different it's
command-line interface
out output it input and output of the
files the form of the files that you
need to feed in to boko Abbott the
format that it spits out is something
that's not immediately usable right it's
not it's not a completely trivial thing
you can't just read it into a panda's
data frame and go and say oh I know what
I'm looking at right so one of the
things that you know we decided to do is
that you know we would in in scenarios
like this if we wanted to stay in the
Python ecosystem we would write write
bind bindings that would allow you to
trend easily transform data to this
format and easily read the data out
but everything else would remain there
we we don't write you know you could of
course write a subprocess call which
would which would call the the the
woeful rabbit utility on the command
line but essentially all we really care
about is like we don't mess with the
outside ecosystem piece of software all
we allow you to do or we allow ourselves
to do is essentially to have a nice way
to interact with the data structures
that it requires and the data formats it
requires so here's a just very fast walk
through we have these text file
streamers which allow you to write
stream files from a certain directory
that that allow you that are totally
paralyzed abode that allow you to take
whatever tokenizer you want create your
own use basic use NLT kay will see that
and second stream that and to local web
at file right you can also look at that
you can look at the output you can do
all sorts of nice filtering things like
you know throw out the words that don't
appear too much throw out the words that
appear too too often etc etc right and
then you go back to a UNIX shell or if
you really care you go you know system
dot sub process or whatnot and you run
vocal rabbit and then we have a nice way
to interact with the results right
here's you know here's what sort of a
local rabbit format file will look like
we'll convert it to something that looks
like that right so this is just this
isn't nothing you should go to reside o
to use local rabbit but this is just a
nice philosophy to do with this extreme
and then stay within your ecosystem to
do the things that you like to do don't
try to like wrap everything right so so
I'm just going to go right to the
summary and then we'll just do a short
demo of exactly what I've been talking
about which i think is it's gonna be
worth more than the words I can bring so
what's the summary of the entire story
right so you pay attention to memory you
pay attention to data structures you
profile for performance your
parallelization is really really easy
for most text processing tasks right
they're independent of each other the
actual entities that the documents use
Python to make your life easier or use
whatever it is that you use are see when
you step out
you know of the ecosystem to make that
easier don't wrap everything in some
awkward way and and don't forget about
command line til ''tis which we write
off right quite a bit of and don't
forget about unix because you know it's
really really good so i'm just gonna
jump to the demo so you guys have
questions yeah go ahead
anomaly detection I believe section is
just an example of of the types of
things that we end up doing quite a bit
with text processing it's just it's just
it's just it's just a an approach that I
like to think it's a paradigm that I
like to think about when trying to give
for example people to trying to give
people access to a large collection
they've never dealt with it's like doing
a cold start problem in archival
research right that you end up doing
that right even you have you have in
that example historians with millions of
documents to look at they don't know
what to look at right they don't know
where to start
what's a nice way to start one nice way
to start is anomaly detection you know
there's something is going on well
they're semantically metadata wires
frequency wise or whatever right and
once you're there then you can think of
other tools right then you can try to
imagine how you would allow people to
find documents that are related or
associated to this given scenario right
if they care about that's a slightly
different that's the next step problem
but that's really what I why I brought
up anomaly detection to begin with
that's right yes right yeah I mean
nominally detection is is exactly that I
mean right you have to define what's
normal then you have to see what stops
stays aside of that but it's not a it's
not it's a paradigm right it's not a
well-defined process cool questions yeah
well I mean a lot of that's I mean
that's an operating system problem right
oh you know you don't have to do you the
question is how do you make sure that
two files aren't read at the same time
so for so for example if you are passing
an iterable or a list right and that
list is a bunch of paths to your file
which are given by some directory crawl
right it's going to pass different file
net file paths to different processes
right so it's sort of like you can get
the paths in serial and then break up
the paths into separate chunks and send
each of those two separate processes
that's right or lines or whatever but I
mean this the operating system handles
writes right so hopefully your operating
system isn't it actually works right
right but I mean that's that's not going
to happen right yeah
you're asking if there are other hyper
parameters which are necessary for LD a
topic modeling yeah but I'm not gonna
get into that go ahead yeah so yeah so
for example one of the things that that
people are interested in at the
classification entering in terms of
network extraction is finding out who is
talking to whom when in these say
government Declassified who was talking
to whom about whom right in these
government cables in the telephone
transcriptions and so on and so on right
so that might be a simple problem like
because you might know who sent the
thing right or it might be a more
involved problem in which it is in that
particular case because you're trying to
actually extract the names themselves
right and you have to make sure you're
extracting actual names of people and
also you have to make sure you are
matching different versions of the same
name to the same person right so Henry
Kissinger and
H Kissinger and some misspelling of
Kissinger is gonna be exactly the same
right so then you built a network of who
is talking to whom how and when and in
what frequency and then you can analyze
the dynamics there
I mean you know in at least in that
particular example you know the network
extraction is slightly you know it's a
different problem from the tokenization
problem meaning that I mean or you can
think of it as a tokenization from where
your tokens are names right so your
tokenizer drops everything except
individual names and then not only does
it drop everything except individual
names it puts all the aliases for the
same name together right that's your
tokenizer function so it's it's it's a
it's a problem in its own right but this
this certainly the paradigm of stream
tokenize and and do you know write that
to somewhere else is is perfectly in
line with that process cool okay so
let's step through this so this is all
joint work with Ian who's who's over
there and it's all in the Rosetta
library which is which has had a release
a few days ago so let's just so let's
begin right I don't need to do the
introduction we've already talked about
pretty much everything so support let's
talk about streamers these are just
directory names so I get the right files
liking this notebook is available in the
library and I can give you the data set
if care about it but it's pretty much
will work with any collection of text
documents right just replace the
directory name to what it what you want
right so so here's a simple example of a
streamer right so here's a simple fire
streamer what is all it's going to do is
it's just going to yield the text of a
file right so let's just look at it like
what does it actually do it there's a
utility we Road which gets all the paths
in a given directory or actually crawls
all those sub directories as well and
then for peeing paths what it does is
that it opens the file right it gets the
tax f dot read and then yields the text
and the only thing you have to notice
about it is that this is actually it's
yielding right it's not returning which
means this is a generator function this
is not a regular function Python which
which is and generative functions are
really quite amazing and quite powerful
there
they essentially create a dot inner and
a dot next methods so they allow you to
create iterables right which is what we
use extensively for everything but I
will just take a look but so if you
wanted like a very very small example
what of what a generator or function or
your interval would look like so just
see what happens here right so I have an
iterable here which is supposed to do
some things until it gets it's supposed
to print a number until he gets to the
nth number which you feed it in our case
five and then it's supposed to stop
right and when it stops it raises a stop
iteration right so here it is we're
printing and then BAM it raises a stop
iteration right so right however if you
feed that into a for loop so what is a
for loop which you've been using for
quite a while essentially what it does
is that it waits for that stop iteration
to happen and then finishes the process
right so so you've been actually
essentially been using generators and
iterate it's implicitly if you've just
been writing for loops okay so let's
just set up a simple stream right so
what is it gonna be oops so here's our
simple stream what kind of an object is
it it's a generator object great and
let's look at what it's gonna do right
so okay it's just screaming all the
information about the files that we have
there right splitting them split line
just it's easier to read right so you
can see these are government documents
okay cool
so let's import a few more things from
Rosetta there's a nice object in the
method in there and it's in the streamer
classes called info stream which
essentially allows you to stream
whatever it is that you want if you want
to be able to tokenize and use the
tokenizer methods it has to stream
something with a text key but you can
put whatever you want in there and as we
talked about before you can cache these
things along the way
right you can throw in you know UNIX
timestamp creation stamps and cache them
along the way and so on and so on so
it's just a convenient way to sort of
organize the information that's coming
in so for example here if you look at
just
Stream necks right it's new things are
happening so we we have the we're
cashing a path we are cashing the
creation time the document ID
modification time size the actual text
and the tokens right things that might
be useful if you don't want to pass over
the data twice right which is one of the
things we want to don't care about okay
and if we want just the text all right
we can just see it here okay and that
might be what we're actually going to be
tokenizing right so so if we want the
tokens so here I'm using a very basic
tokenizer that we wrote that's part of
the library which you can use whatever
you want you see right we're just
producing calling dot next it's
producing the tokens for everything for
the next document all right but you can
use the NLT Kay tokenizer if you want
you can seal pretty slightly different
things more allows for more new merits
because one of the defaults is no
numerix and hours okay cool now we get
to some of the vocal Abbot stuff right
so we ran that ran on a thousand
documents if it was if the dataset was a
little bit longer you could have seen it
blow up my my memory here but it's
pretty small so so we just created a
vocal wabbit format tokenized format for
all the documents in the in the
collection right can Ren I'm not gonna
run this in command line but you run
that and command line it takes about two
seconds in this particular case we load
the file alright this is all the Python
and then we can get to look at what's
actually happening all right okay so
we're seeing these are the words we see
these are the counts the tokens score
the fraction of the documents they
appear in and so on and so on right
explore the results a little bit further
all right we can look at what words
appear in topic twelve right so one of
the things I kind of glossed over here
is that I picked by default twenty
topics
20 groups of words of text that the that
the LDA a topic model is going to create
right that's one of the things you have
to know a priori is the number of topics
you're gonna have so here we have you
know document fraction the the topic of
the document frequency the token score
and the actual actual word that that
appears we can actually look at what
these topics look like and we print out
the first ten words of these things here
they are here's topic seven topic a
topic nine and so on and so on you know
they might be meaningful to you in
context they might be just things you're
gonna use as a feature and then we can
take any given document and just easily
plot what its topic distribution is
these are just ranked in an order of
probability yeah
and I just say the first ten yeah so
everything is just ordered right you see
the probability this top topic is this
probability of this topic is that
probability as before is that that that
that yeah and then just generate some
random colors here it doesn't plot for
some reason great I might not have
pushed it great I'm not online okay
we're gonna stop right here
but you sin chily what we did here was
that we took a collection of documents
we streamed him we tokenized that
everything was in parallel we moved it
to a format local avid format and we
were able to just read off the results
and play with the results and and and
explore that and that's actually a
fairly it looks trivial but it's
actually a fairly involved process if
you're gonna do it from the start yeah
but I work this way you mean in the
ipython notebook yeah we do a lot of I
do a lot of exploratory data analysis
and ipython notebook this isn't the way
I write code right I'll write code and a
standard you know like whim environment
but this is definitely a great way to
see things right away as opposed to
having them pop up yeah it's um it's 0.2
state right this 0.24 as of this morning
or yesterday so it's you know it's there
are it's fairly well tested I mean
everything's tested pretty much that we
can test so there's you know there's
people who use it I mean it's it's
definitely ready for use
there's not like any you can pip install
it and and you can do this and and you
can do this and variants of this or I
saw Boco a bit aside but you're
basically good to go you can take the
streamers this is there's a bunch of
different types of streamers file
streamers generic streamers and soda and
so on and tokenizer x' and things like
that and no definitely I'm definitely
not satisfied you know one of the things
you know I wouldn't even know where to
start all the things we want to add I
mean there's a there's a whole bunch of
there's some natural language processing
that we'd like to make faster think
about there is a whole bunch of database
plugins you know database driver type
things that there aren't any right
there's a nice text file streamer which
allows you to just give me a base
directory and let me do all these things
with all the files that I find in the
crawl there's a nice generic streamer
which says like give me anything that
iterates and returns text that's an
iterable that it and it returns
something with a a text key great right
whatever that might be but there isn't
something that says like hey give me an
S MySQL connection right and you know it
because we have to you know you have to
think about what does that mean to
stream because of how am i scale queries
are done but there is a way to think
about that
there is you can't actually control the
cursor that's not written [ __ ] so
that's a big thing that I'd like to do
that I think is important
Ian what do you think what's like the
next big thing you'd want to happen I
don't know okay no but I think yeah
database connections would be awesome
yeah it's just you have to do it
yourself now and I think it would be a
nice piece go ahead
I mean the question the question is
let's say I'm just gonna repeat yeah the
question is why not go with Hadoop why
not go with like a big MapReduce type of
framework and and this and and and why
use quote expensive hardware the answer
is that it's not expensive the hard will
surely use right I think I think we're
using you know builds all these things
in my laptop for the most part I like to
do the example of the big machine but we
never actually even used it right I mean
we we was owned by somebody else and we
were no longer there basically by the
time we could have used but the point is
that all these big distributive system
frameworks are complicated and very very
restrictive Hadoop is restrictive in
what you can do and it also requires a
lot of overhead to make this thing run
we don't do anything complicated we just
work with it we know we work with disk
IO we worked with basic memory work just
within the computer and and and and a
lot of these things that were done were
were you know we would create incredible
overhead and many many problems which
are not necessary to solve these that's
really the reality it's there solving
hadoop solves a different problem we
don't have that problem
the scaling problem here is not Google
scaling problem here is mainly stable
even wanted to say something in terms of
roadmap or in terms of things to add I
think some integration with scikit-learn
and examples showing like so we have a
nice sort of well played out example
going through though going through the
LD a portion of Volvo Abbott yeah what
about going through some of the other
Volvo Abbott pipelines the Volvo web it
does a lot more than LD a and in all
cases the output format isn't a panda's
data frame which is what you would like
here so why not you know if people can
work with it so that the output of vocal
wabbits linear models can be fed into
the data frame that would be great or
just examples showing the output being
fed into scikit-learn that's right the
we added in les release there's a - we
allow you to output the formant to a
scipy sparse matrix right which is what
sort of the first step if you want to
work you want to be compatible with a
scaler
however that's just
step right we don't have examples of
that and we we don't have you know there
going to be other things people get a
lot of it go ahead
so the question is about about building
Lda models right so basically the the
the model / the the model output isn't
is cached in a file right it's written
to file so you you know everything about
your semantic distribution right so
basically you can take a new document I
could have demonstrated this but I
didn't you take a new document you
tokenize it in the same way and you do a
comparison like basically a cosine
similarity of its affinity to the topics
versus the affinity of all the other
documents to the topics right so then
it's totally portable it's just a file
as long as you have the bindings to read
it yeah go ahead
so the so the two obvious examples so
for example the the I had two examples
right so I had the legal example right
that was about six to seven hundred
thousand documents originally they're
different their size is varied from fair
so it was is the the legal data was 140
gigabytes yes at the end the the I can't
answer what the I don't have a perfect
sense of what the declassification
engine database is because it's always
growing and but the different
collections are you know we're talking
roughly the same couple hundred gigs two
to three hundred gigs if you're working
with a particular collection or sub
collection but if things go the way
they're going to be going they're going
to be the volumes are going to grow it
pretty much exponentially with these
because more and more is being released
and more and more being available to the
to the researchers yep
well the number of features you have
well that really depends on your choice
of tokenizer it depends on your choice
of filter it depends on your know you
can't take everything well I mean you so
you pick the thing so the thing that
determines how you pick your features is
partly experimentation partly some some
natural language processing analysis
right some some exploratory data
analysis right so I don't remember off
the top of my head how many features we
had but I had like we had in the in the
legal 300 400 yeah for this case
remember we were doing we took the topic
weights as features so we take say 50
topic weights and 50 metadata items and
200 other hand shows and words and those
were features no no go ahead
I mean these were domain expertise
chosen words so I mean remember there's
sort of two things we're talking about
here one is the LDA pipeline which is
where the features are the words and for
you could have 20,000 different words so
you could have 20,000 different features
but it's a very sparse dataset and the
other is after you come up with LD a
topic weights you can feed those in as
features into say a random forest but
then you can't work with 20,000 features
in a random forest you're gonna work
with say a few hundred and and the
reason we were we
and the reason you work with a few
hundred is not because you throw out all
the words is because in that particular
case we actually we just had reg X's
which stood for aliases of all the words
we cared about right it's it's like it
was just had more flexible things than
stemming right per se we we needed it
for that particular thing that but reg X
that reg X file
right the the file of reg X is used to
create the features was done through
exploratory data analysis as well as
domain knowledge that's why we're not
talking about you know
might have been 220 thousand words or
tokens that went into the LDA which
produced 50 features and then there
might have been another 250 redexes
which stood for god knows how many
actual token words right but the actual
feature set was fairly small and but it
was very good it was flexible and
representative in different ways of the
corpus we were working with that make
sense
it I completely agree but there's no but
there is no reason we take the most
frequent features right but the we take
the features that are indicative of
whatever it is that we're trying to do
so for example you know you're trying to
classify relevant versus route non
relevant in the legal case and you know
what relevant means and you know you
have a training set right that doesn't
mean you're gonna take the most frequent
words here in the most frequent words
there right that's not that's not
necessarily true you might take the work
you know you might take the words that
only appear here and only appear there
imagine you have a word that appears you
know fifty percent of your relevant
documents it appears in zero percent of
your own documents but only appears once
and these because it's like made of you
know so you take that one right so
there's that that that there's no
there's no inherent process of how we
build the feature set right that comes
from the problem at hand and I think it
always has to come from the problem at
hand aside you know like you know maybe
deep learning type of fire stuff but
that's not the problem here
go ahead one more question and then you
can just bug me afterwards I'm sorry
could you repeat
is there a disadvantage to using
stochastic gradient descent type models
I mean the whatever disadvantage you you
you know whatever loss of accuracy you
could pretend there's no inherent reason
why stochastic gradient descent optimize
you know random forests is gonna be or a
logo a Bedell da is gonna perform worse
than something else right but the
reality is that something that is an
online process is infinitely scalable
and that's that that we need to have for
these things to work to not rebuild it
for every data set right I think that
we're gonna have to that's we're gonna
have to wrap up at this point but you
can pass me afterwards but yeah let's